on est toute la
famille ça va dire les trois du drapeau
occasion brille un peu moins aujourd'hui
violent légère aurait été connu pour son
personnage la Sagouine écrit par sa
grande amie Anthony demayet et moi si
j'ai été connu c'est un peu à cause de
la Sagouine donc à cause de Viola et
aujourd'hui nous formons un trio et je
peux dire que c'est un peu cet acadique
que vous perdez aujourd'hui
de 3000 fois à travers le monde
personnage auquel elle a été fortement
attachée elle est plus qu'une Sagouine
elle est une violente elle a joué
d'autres rôles elle a joué elle a
enseigné elle a été une personnalité
forte en Acadie personnalité
rassembleuses le président de sa
fondation croit que son œuvre restera
longtemps dans l'imaginaire des gens il
est entré dans toutes les cuisines dans
tous les villages dans les villes
pas seulement académie mais au Québec
dans l'Ouest canadien c'est une grande
dame du théâtre
ministre fédéral Dominique Leblanc se
rappelle de l'avoir vu interprété la
Sagouine avant de la côtoyer comme c'est
matrice il y a pas de doute que l'impact
qu'elle a eu en termes de définir la
culture acadienne de donner une voix au
peuple acadien pas seulement au Canada
mais à travers le monde
j'imitais la Sagouine quand j'allais à
l'école j'avais pas du tout ce que je
faisais mais j'imitais la Sagouine puis
elle m'a donné le goût de faire de la
scène le club blanc l'un des nombreux
comédiens avoir été inspiré par l'oeuvre
de violents légères qui la côtoyé
pendant plus d'une vingtaine d'années
sur les planches il croit qu'elle a
ouvert la porte aux artistes acadiens
pour rayonner plus largement ça nous a
donné l'espoir que c'était possible et
là aujourd'hui on réalise que c'est
possible fondée en 1992 le pays de la
Sagouine véritable parc qui donne vie à
l'oeuvre elle a représentation même de
l'impact de Viola légère selon la
directrice générale
ce lieu aujourd'hui a comme mission de
faire rayonner la culture acadienne je
veux dire je sais pas s'il y a un plus
grand l'aigle que ça tout s'entend pour
dire que la communauté acadienne a comme
devoir d'honorer le travail de Viola
légère à jamais il faut qu'on continue à
faire rayonner la culture l'accent le
patrimoine linguistique préserver se
prendre soin de le partager avec le
monde entier c'est ce que violent
faisait puis c'est ce qu'elle aurait
voulu que nous en face